hello everybody Jake here and welcome
back to another Elden ring discussion
video today I wanted to talk about the
ultimate question the most important
question that I have in regards to the
lore and a question that can answer so
many other questions and that is simply
why did Queen America shatter the Elden
ring I think it's sort of amazing that
well over a year later Post Release that
we still don't know definitively why she
chose to do this we can guess and make
interpretations as to the most likely
cases which we will discuss today but
the only major sources of reasoning as
to why this happened is in the opening
cutscene
great Elden ring
was shattered
Queen Marica the eternal
is nowhere to be found
we can also get some extra Insight on
this from Elden Ring's story trailer
where it starts with the Knight of black
knives
starting with Godwin the golden
Queen Marico was driven to the brink
the shattering ensued a war that roared
only Darkness
Elder ring was broken
to why
and finally there's some dialogue from
Roger that can help us understand the
timeline of this event it happened
during the Golden Age of the ERD tree
long before the shattering of the Elden
ring someone stole a fragment of the
Rune of Death From malacath the Black
Blade and on a bitter night murdered
Godwin the golden that was the first
recorded death of a demigod in all
history and it became the Catalyst soon
the Elden ring was smashed and thus
sprang forth the war known as the
shattering I once wished to become a
scholar you see I've spent many an hour
scouring the archives for knowledge of
that fateful plot the world has grown
crooked and if you intend to put it to
rights you'd better understand what
happened to make it this way
now this dialogue by Roger is vitally
important to understanding everything
that's happened because it seems like
there's still some confusion within the
community I received this comment that
says people need to realize that the
Knight of black knives is implied to
have happened shortly after the Eldon
ring was shattered by the intro the
story trailer and Roger's dialogue now I
sort of understand getting confused by
the intro cinematic because it does
portray the Alden ring being shattered
into America Vanishing and then
showcasing the Knight of black knives
into the shattering War which is
different from the shattering of the
Elden ring however we did just watch the
story trailer and it's made clear by
Ronnie that it all started with death
being stolen Godwin being killed the
Elden ring being shattered America going
missing and then the war starting and we
just heard Roger say the same that the
death of Godwin was the Catalyst the
start of it all so at least we can be
sure about that I think the intro is
this show case to us a bit out of
sequence and that's all I do find it
sort of interesting that in the story
trailer Ronnie doesn't know who broke
the Elden ring or why it happened at all
when we do know that she fully admits in
the game that she is the one who started
the plot to kill Godwin I stole a
fragment to the Rune of death
and used it to forge the god slaying
black knives through fearsome right
I did it all I have slain the body I was
born into and cast it away I performed
the ACT not to bury the past
nor in Shame of the deed there's nothing
wrong with a well-laid scheme so we can
really tell here that Ronnie was
confident in her plot and has no regrets
in orchestrating it I think it is
possible that Ronnie even in the story
trailer is manipulating you into helping
her perform her tasks for her even
before we started the game even owned
the game it would be an incredible
example of foreshadowing by from
software if this was the case unless of
course
thou should take the crowd
so now that we have established a
sequence of events we can come to the
most likely conclusion as to why Queen
America shattered the Elden ring and I
think it's explained beautifully by Finn
who said I really kind of think her main
motivation was just grief for the death
of Godwin given that he was America's
firstborn son was born in the ER tree's
age of abundance and had the full title
of Godwin the golden he definitely
represented the grace and beauty of the
golden order to America so she probably
had great love for him unlike some of
her other children like The Omen twins
Godwin is very much a balder figure a
Norse god of beauty with golden hair who
died in an assassination when supposedly
nothing in the world could kill him
America would then be equated with
balder's mother frigg or possibly even
Freya both golden-haired goddesses of
fertility Beauty war and even death in
Norse mythology Baldur's death is the
inciting event that starts Ragnarok
which is the battle between the gods
that destroys the old world and makes
way for a new one America shattered the
Elden ring due to the grief at the loss
of her Golden Sun and the loss of her
faith in the golden order leading to the
shattering war and battle between the
demigods can be seen as her
intentionally starting Ragnarok
especially with the direct parallels of
the burning of the earth tree and the
destruction of the world tree idrisil
Jake if you read this far I'm high and
the ADHD told me to lore this is
perfectly explained Finn you are clearly
smoking that good so while I think
this is the most plausible reasoning
it's still up in the air somewhat
nothing is truly solidified and that can
be frustrating for some people like this
comment that says honestly the fact that
something as crucial as this remains a
mystery over a year after the game
released is some of my biggest problems
with golden ring while I understand the
frustration I don't agree that it's a
problem having a single solid answer to
everything would just make the story
less meaningful and in reality almost
nothing is this straightforward we make
decisions every day based on so many
different factors and experiences that
differ from person to person in all
likelihood America probably had many
different personal reasons for
shattering the Elden ring that can't be
summed up as easily as she did it for
the Vine I think we could go over tons
of different reasons as to why she did
this but ultimately I think doing so
would lead to just more confusion if you
have a theory as to why she did it you
could be right but here's what I believe
America was driven to the brink because
her world and her family were not
perfect like it was expected to be
America was split between understanding
the faults of her order and completely
converging it America clearly wants to
change the world but as the vassal for
the Elden ring wanting this clearly goes
against the greater Will's wishes she
even goes as far as to mock radagon for
just blindly following the order oh
radican
Leo Hound of the golden order Thou Art
yet to become me
the art yet to become a God let us be
shattered
both
mine other self
she's at odds with herself figuratively
and literally I believe this is the
major reason that America and radagon
were split they are literally two
opposite halves of the same hole one
side wanting to break the Alden ring and
the other wanting to repair it and
through this frustration she was pushed
to the brink when her Golden Sun was
killed in a night of wintry Fog she
thought enough was enough and just as
Ronnie likely planned it to be America
shattered the Alden ring and started a
major change in the world as we find out
at the end of the game America's
disappearance was the greater will
imprisoning her inside of the archery
using radagon as a sort of mold to keep
her and the Eldon ring somewhat together
while we bring the rest of the pieces to
them and when we fight radagon I truly
believe this is not radagon at all it's
just a portrayal of him or his body is
used as a puppet by the greater will to
attack the greater will couldn't let the
world see that their God was the very
reason their world had been broken and
if the people were to find out well we
can see what their reaction would be
from Corin a devoted follower of the
golden order
[Laughter]
comedy look at it
of perfection burning
before our fairy eyes
laughs
thank you all for watching I hope you
enjoyed it please let me know what you
think down in the comments and if there
is a video topic you'd like to see
discussed have a great rest of your day
and I'll see you in the next one take
care